our Kelly created and occupied a
position of outrageousness that can mask
everything that was happening behind the
scenes
by now you've either seen or heard of
life time surviving our Kelly six-part
documented two-hour Kelly sexual
misconduct ET is here to break down the
top most shocking confessions from
alleged victims the biggest red flags
and the mute our Kelly movement sparked
after years about Regis behavior with
underage girls when the door flew open
on the bus Robbie was having sex with
Aaliyah
okay so fans are up said that the late
allele was included in the docu-series
but I feel like this relationship is a
big piece of the puzzle it's just the
beginning and it's one of the biggest
red flags absolutely he was 27 years old
when he secretly got married to a 15
year old Aaliyah eventually that
marriage was annulled by her parents but
she was just 12 years old when they met
exactly and of course we don't know all
of the details when they met but married
at 15 is really young now aleeah's
family has spoken out about claims made
in the documentary and they are denying
all claims
don't be afraid
all the way
so some other red flags are that he
produced music for alia that addressed a
teenage girl trying to go all the way
with an older man
I know age ain't nothing but a number is
a very classic songul when you listen to
the lyrics it's all there in plain sight
now our Kelly also talked about how he
was molested as a child between seven
and fourteen by a family member as some
experts have said sometimes trauma can
spill over but I don't think that that's
really an excuse here we're just giving
you background yep and our Kelly's
explicit music and raunchy performances
were hiding in plain sight calling
himself the piped piper of R&B leading
children away from music to never be
seen again it makes me sick to my
stomach guys like it's just so much to
take in and if you guys watch you know
exactly how we're feeling now one of the
most heartbreaking confessions comes
from his ex-wife Andrea Kelly a lot of
victims have spoken up about claims that
they experienced isolation manipulation
abuse but Andrea opening up about her
attempted suicide is so sad and never
going out on the balcony
[Music]
and climbing up on the ledge like god I
can't take another day I can't do this
anymore
here taking me to a place that was
willing to leave my people I cannot even
begin to imagine being in an abusive
marriage for 13 years with children who
had to live through the child
pornography cases that literally sounds
like a living nightmare
absolutely and something else that came
out as far as a shocking confession
Andrea almost lost her child Robert jr.
a during delivery due to the stress from
those trials I mean guys this like she
said is the nightmare yeah it's because
of you Robert that my children were told
they can't sit at the lunch table cuz
your daddy rates little girls you can
deny all you want to and for that you
can go to hell our Kelly's former backup
singer Sparkle also came forward
identify her 14 year old niece shown in
the viral sex tape
have never introduced her to him
how dare you
I think this was a part of the
docu-series that actually made me shed
tears because she really is taking on a
burden and that's something that she has
to live with as an on introducing them
but many had mixed reactions about
another alleged victim Lisa Van Allen's
confession she is of course the are
Kelly's longtime girlfriend who
performed sexual acts with sparkles nice
now they started dating at 17 and she
claims that she stopped messing with
sparkles nice when she found out that
she was 14 the Internet has spoken for
itself but guys it was really just tough
in general to watch these victims come
forward so et spoke to Sparkle about to
the docu-series and here's what she had
to say what did you think while you
watch this hey I was disgusted I was
heartbroken I cried I yelled I screamed
you know it was so disheartened because
Robert and I were like brother and
sister I thought so since the series has
aired stars have been coming out in
droves speaking out in outrage
joining the mute or Kelly movement
included in those celebrities are
chancellor rapper neo and taint now Jada
pinkett-smith has come forward she's a
little confused because sales streaming
sales for Spotify shot up after the
docu-series and I'm just as confused as
Jada I really would like for you guys to
help me understand what I'm missing even
if it even if I'm missing something that
I don't necessarily agree with John
Legend who appeared in the Doc you
series also took to Twitter he wrote to
everyone telling me how courageous I am
for appearing in the doc it didn't feel
risky at all
I believe these women and don't give up
about protecting a serial child rapist
easy decision while there are a lot of
stars who are outraged by this
docu-series there are still some loyal
r.kelly fans who feel like this
conversation is old it happened decades
ago he has not been convicted and it's
sad to see the society sometimes puts
the musician and the music over someone
else's personal life when it's as
outrageous as these claims have been I
mean it just makes me sick me too and we
are in a new age
you know this is the age of believing
the survivors believing the victims and
I think that's important and I think we
need to stop supporting the musicians
and the artists and the people in
general who are hurting people
absolutely not time's up
time is up exactly how now there's still
a lot to unpack here of course ET we'll
keep you updated with the latest has
more details and reaction surface over
this series our Kelly of course is
denied all accusations brought against
him and has never been convicted of
these crimes but in the meantime be sure
to subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm at Halle underscore Stephens
and I'm at cording the underscore teza
no bye for now
[Music]